我告诉大家一个好玩的方法
这个方法对你来说是有用的
作为很多老伙企点击的关于次媒体的
我给你献挂一个关于那么多次媒体的
首先告诉你的第一件事情是什么
如果你用眼睛的方式
用眼睛的方式
将围去做短视频
那么我告诉你一次调视频是干过我众的干活
你可以想象一下一个人一上来
讲了东西和短视频里的内容的知识的密度和深度是不一样的
而且你完全是各位是一进到底
你不需要去切这个是完全不一样的
第三 第三 就是你的随意想
就是有些时候人看短视频看什么呢
看短视频是看你的状态
你看 很多老伙传说我有这个文案
我用的文案行不行
我告诉你其实是不行的
为什么不行
因为你会发现我身上有一种东西你很难学到
什么的东西就是这种随意行
对吧 这种随意行
就是我不在乎
我随意 我很轻松就完成了
这个部分的话就好多人在
很人一只想少那种感觉
就是很轻松的 那种松子感
很多人做不到的 对不对
各位你看很多人他就做短视频
干嘛呢 就是很早有人就写好搞子
然后一点一点企业 那个是很难的
一开始就端着但是松子感觉很难做到的
还有一个部分 我告诉大家
就是天下没有白走的路
就是你在口不喝的时候你的状态
你的神态
你的眉毛 各位你看我的眉毛
他们我的眉毛会说话
然后你看那个我们说真自委
这个眼睛会放电
我的眼睛也会放电
是吧 我的眼睛也会放电
然后口气 说话的口气
顿错 顿错
就是这个挺顿
这个东西都是功夫
然后你会发现你用这种
太的方式去做短视频
尤其知识类的口剥的短视频
其实就是短微的短微